[Musik]
ich bin in der russischen kultur
metropole sankt petersburg vor mir liegt
eine aufgabe die mindestens drei nummern
zu groß ist
aber wie sagt meine frau bescheidenheit
ist etwas für pechvögel zum abschluss
meiner langjährigen korrespondenten zeit
möchte ich bei der weihnachtsmesse in
einem der besten kenner der stadt
mitsingen sich der laie inmitten von
profis
[Musik]
[Applaus]
euro
[Musik]
ein freund aus alten tagen hat wie ihr
den kontakt zum dirigenten vermittelt
ich dachte anfänglich es sei ein kleiner
chor jetzt habe ich herausgefunden es
ist ein code der top liga gleich drei
fichten dirigenten zum vorsingen
seien sie gegrüßt christoph haben sie
sprechen muss ich ja mit alpinem akzent
setzen sie sich ich bin echt nervös
die geschichte kennen sie das ist
vielleicht nicht entschuldigen sie ich
spreche leider keine großen stunden ich
hatte immer den wunsch zu singen
ich habe jahrelang konzept organisiert
für einen kleinen chor aus sankt
petersburg
ich habe immer nur zugehört sicher 50
bis 100 mal und da kam der wunsch auf
einmal wirklich singen zu lernen
ich kann keine noten lesen sie es ich
dachte es ein kleiner chor jetzt habe
ich rausgefunden wie chor singt auf
höchstem niveau
wir versuchen es einfach
doch
was soll ich nach singen ja das kann ich
nicht versuchen sie ich kann das nie
aufgibt
[Musik]
dollar
ja
[Musik]
was soll es auf geht's
schauen sie sie haben es schon bis zur
note d geschafft das ist die gründe für
die beiden stimme ich denke sie haben
gute anlagen aber sie sei nicht
entwickelt verstehen sie ja ich verstehe
man spürt dass sie im fernsehen
professionell sprechen
[Musik]
jetzt müssten ein japanischer stand ich
habe ihm erklärt dass ihr kollege
champions league sind
ich habe bräuchte die vierte liga
höchstens zuerst einmal sollten sie es
versuchen zumindest mal ein lied in der
weiteren stimme oder 2 wir werden sie
ich glaube einst reich
nicht nur der chor auf topniveau
verunsichert mich auch der ort wo alles
stattfinden soll
die imposante isaaks kathedrale einer
der touristischen hotspots von sankt
petersburg
[Musik]
jeden tag sind akut in wechselnder
zusammensetzung in einem seitenaltar und
begleitet den orthodoxen gottesdienst
[Musik]
dirigent hat mich eingeladen
vorbeizukommen
ich solle mich zwischen die chorsänger
stellen um ein gespür zu bekommen
ich hoffe bloß dass die chormitglieder
alles professionelle sänger diese aktion
nicht allzu daneben finden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
euro
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bis 2
o
[Musik]
sind sie zufrieden es klingt sehr
kraftvoller hat das in chur gefallen
ja sehr denken sie es würde ihr gelingen
ja und nein es klingt großartig viel zu
gut für mich
wie machen wir die zweite
darüber müssen jetzt nachdenken muss wir
denken sie nach worauf habe ich mich da
bloß eingelassen
doch der dirigent will die übung noch
nicht abbrechen
er will mir noten schicken zu mögen
auch die sänger scheinen kein problem
damit zu haben im gegenteil die jüngst
im chor hat mich zu sich nach hause
eingeladen
ein glücksfall denn ich möchte wieder
mal sehen wie es hinter den prachtvollen
von sankt petersburg aussieht sie wohnt
in einer kommunal k eine art wege
kommunistische pflegen
so wurde ich auch als ich vor 25 jahren
meine ersten russland- erfahrungen
machte aber das ist schon sehr lange her
seit ich das letzte mal in einer
kommunal cover tatsächlich existiert
diese wohnform in sankt petersburg noch
oft vor allem im stadtzentrum wo die
wohnungen immer teurer werden
übrigens auch ein gewisser jan immel
putin ist in sankt petersburg in einer
kommunal k aufgewachsen
danke leid hier gemütlich hier ist unser
zimmer
wir haben torten für alle mitgebracht
ich habe auch eine torte
das mache nicht wunderbar machen sie es
sich gemütlich
habt ihr die wohnung gekauft
ja gekauft also ein zimmer
sehr schön direkt am kanal schön dann
für fragen wie viel das zimmer gekostet
hat 1,3 millionen dass sie in wien euro
circa 20.000 früher waren es 40 des 20
für dieses geld bekommt man außerhalb
eine ganze wohnung aber hier im zentrum
ist es natürlich viel schöner
ich finde die aussicht so schön ich
musste sie einfach haben
das gut die gäste sind schon hier das
ist mein geliebter frank sinatra
er ist mein absoluter liebling
was mögen sie seien charismas die
stimmlage die musikalität
sein ganzes werk er ist ein einmaliger
musiker
[Musik]
ja
vor
leipzig sitzt
daria und die ehemaligen teilen sich die
kommunal kam mit 16 menschen und einem
dutzend haustiere
naja
[Musik]
die kommunal card zwölf zimmer ein bad
und zwei küchen
wir möchten gerne mit ihnen sprechen wir
haben doch abgemacht dass du mich war's
bevor die leute kommen da hast du mich
aber in eine unangenehme situation
gebracht so wie ich aussehe
das ist doch nicht schlimm alles bestens
marina wohnt hier seit wann 680
erzählen sie uns doch wie es zu solchen
zeit war
ach es war genauso wie heute hat sich
nichts verändert
nein bloß ein badezimmer gab es damals
noch nicht das war ein stelle des parks
gar nichts worauf man sich zu waschen
hier in der küche hat man die kinder
gebadet wir haben eine kleine wanne
hingestellt und wasser gekocht weil es
damals nur kaltes gab
wir passen uns dem leben an wir finden
für jede situation einen ausweg
können sie uns das badezimmer zeigen
schrecklich schrecklich
das macht nichts ich hatte früher auf
science ein badezimmer für alle und es
ist wirklich schlimm
man müsste eigentlich einen helm tragen
nichts was ist da oben das ist eine
einsturzgefährdete wohnung damit die
leute vom vierten stock nicht plötzlich
in unserer wanne liegen haben wir diese
stützen installiert da gehst du dich nun
plötzlich fängst du den nachbarn von
oben auf
in diesem badezimmer will man sich nicht
lange aufhalten
deshalb haben wir auch nie eine schlange
vor dem bad drei torten haben wir also
[Musik]
von welcher torte möchten sie egal
karamell oder cognac ja dann cognac das
ist mein ehemann und nicht als ich vor
25 jahren hier ankam konnte ich nur
einen satz auf russisch als passives
rasche gast bremst war
danke für ihre gastfreundschaft dieser
satz fasst auch heute noch werden daher
noch ausgeht heute nacht heißt es für
mich vorerst abschied nehmen von sankt
petersburg
[Musik]
die noten vom dirigenten sind noch nicht
gekommen
dafür sind meine zweifel zurück aber
kaum angefangen kann ich ja nicht schon
wieder aufgeben
zum glück habe ich zu hause
professionelle unterstützung meine
tochter maria ist ein gesangstalent mit
alten russischen liedern hat sie in
einem talentwettbewerb im russischen
fernsehen für furore gesorgt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in lima posten
[Applaus]
branimir das bibel vorsprung ging der
liebert wohl wahrscheinlicher wird
buschkowsky damit erhofft wurde wie die
profis geben
das nie
[Musik]
matthias gesangslehrerin marina musst
mir helfen
zurück in moskau wo ich seit zehn jahren
lebe treffe ich mich mit ihr
[Musik]
sie machen aus mir einen sänger einen
sängern einen bariton wir uns mehr geben
maria sagte ich müsse aus dem bauch
singen und nicht aus dem kopf die atmung
genau aber ich muss bei null anfangen
die erste gesangsstunde meines lebens
und das in einem studie namens jimmy
hendrix schon ziemlich eigenartig das
ganze also wie lange können sie einen
ton halten
das weiß ich nicht nehmen sie einen
beliebigen ton und den lauterer oder
einen der ihnen genehm ist so einfach
ich kann sehr lange ich habe diese
gelungen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
gegen wieso ich habe ein lungenvolumen
wie ein spitzensportler sagte einst ein
arzt von natur aus können sie jetzt
versuchen so zu sehen dass der ton nicht
funkt also ohne vibrato
am besten sie machen es an der wand
stellen sie sich vor sie würden die wand
bewegen wir mit den händen dorthin
[Musik]
bewegen sie ich habe richtig angst aber
sie bewegt sich nicht
man hat das gefühl sie haben angst sie
zu bewegen sie müssen sie mehr sowie
einen schrank wegschieben
[Musik]
jetzt ist er gerade jetzt ist der ton
richtig sie haben richtig dosiert das
machen sie schon ganz gut
immerhin etwas ja sagen sie wem haben
sie vorgesungen
vielleicht kennen sie ich denke er nicht
werde ist dirigent manchmal auch am
mariinsky theater als sie ihm vor
gesungen haben
was hat er ihnen gesagt er sagte ich
sein bariton da hat er ihnen aber eine
schwierige aufgabe gegeben
bariton befindet sich in der mitte
zwischen der hohen männer partie unter
ganz tiefen ist das schwierig das ist
die schwierigste aufgabe es ist eben
genau zwischen trennen die hören und
tieferen stimmen hatten melodien
das ist einfacher für das dazwischen
braucht man ein sehr gutes dass er ihnen
eine solche aufgabe gegeben hat bedeutet
dass er entweder sehr stark an sie
glaubt es ist die mega
die lektion hat mich körperlich
geschafft aber ich habe viel gelernt und
bin motiviert doch die noten sind immer
noch nicht gekommen
von dirigenten habe ich seit meinem
vorsingen nichts mehr gehört
[Musik]
ich habe beruflich in sankt petersburg
zu tun vielleicht kann ich den
dirigenten kurz treffen indes lew ist
viel beschäftigt und oft unterwegs im in
und ausland
es ist mir irgendwie unangenehm ihn zu
stören
vielleicht will er ja gar nicht mehr
dass ich an weihnachten mitsingen
trotzdem es ist für mich immer wieder
eine freude in der ehemaligen hauptstadt
zu sein
wo du siehst du auch einen nicht sagen
nicht nur in einen süßen früher habe ich
immer schon mal gegessen
da hatte doch tatsächlich eine kollegin
behauptet dass da menschen fleisch drin
sein könnte man sollte es auf keinen
fall auf der straße essen kannst du dir
das vorstellen
das war in den 90ern was machen sie für
eine sendung schwizer aus der schweiz
über sankt petersburg wie gefällt ihnen
die stadt hervorragend
basti ruhe besser als in moskau ein foto
macht klar was ist schön
da wir fragen wie wann sie geboren sind
19 93 93 ernsthaft 93 bin ich das erste
mal hierher gekommen damals 1993 hatte
ich natürlich keine ahnung dass sich der
einst als korrespondent aus dem
riesenreich berichten wird ich wollte
eigentlich nur zwei wochen bleiben etwas
russisch lernen
ich blieb vorerst für zwei monate
dass russland virus hatte mich gepackt
obwohl die verhältnisse damals kurz nach
dem ende der sowjetunion äußerst prekär
werden
nicht zu vergleichen mit dem blühenden
sankt petersburg von heute doch sankt
petersburg hatte schon immer eine sehr
wechselvolle geschichte
obwohl noch heute viele bürger der stadt
in eher ärmlichen verhältnissen leben
prosperiert die metropole in der 5
millionen menschen wohnen es wird viel
gebaut
bei dirigent live immer noch funkstille
dafür treffe ich alex der einzige sänger
im chor dennoch einen nebenjob hat er
ist immobilienmakler
heute will er eine frau und ihrem sohn
eine ein zimmer wohnung verkaufen
fertig ausgebaut 1600 euro
sind sie in der wohnung hier
guten abend guten abend ist dass das
tolle viertel das sie uns zeigen wollten
wenn wir uns anschauen wollen müssen wir
los solange es noch hell ist
los geht's schauen sie sich das viertel
mal vergleichen sie es mit dem dass sie
kennen den sie selber leben und mit dem
zentrum das ist schon hübsch das sind
die eindrücke sind ja das erste mal hier
es ist ganz ähnlich wie in europa ein
bisschen
wissen sie dieses vierte leist wien
es ist der österreichischen hauptstadt
nachempfunden der österreichischen haut
durch das neubauviertel liegt etwa 50
minuten vom zentrum entfernt und soll
eine größere werdende mittelschicht
ansprechen
insgesamt gefällt es mir in einer
musterwohnung will alexej seine kunden
restlos von einem kauf überzeugen
[Musik]
das ist es schwierig hier eine wohnung
zu finden
im prinzip nein man hat er die qual der
wahl
es ist schwierig sich zu entscheiden
weil es sehr viele angebote gibt
frage wo das nachfrage
wieso gibt es so viele angebote hat man
zuvor gebaut dass die nachfrage gesunken
männer viel gebaut als die wirtschaft
jetzt ist die wirtschaft rückläufig und
die nachfrage ist zurückgegangen
schauen wir uns die kirche und eine
schöne große küche schauen sie der
balkon ist oben und unten das glas so
haben sie viel sonnenlicht
[Musik]
wir denken darüber nach und ruft männern
jungs das was ich morgen telefonieren
wir noch mal wieso verkaufen sie
wohnungen und singen nicht nur immer nur
dasselbe sein darf man richtigen stellen
sie sich vor sie sitzen bei tisch und
schokolade kekse und wenn die seele sind
ist das etwas sehr leckeres süßes aber
wenn das mittag ist bloß aus süßigkeiten
bestellt und ist nie fleisch gibt wie
gemüse ist das fleisch das ist das
fleisch
spätere fahrig dass alexej die wohnung
verkaufen konnte ich bin zurück im
zentrum
mir ist etwas peinliches passiert und
ich muss den dirigenten löw anrufen
die
da ja guten abend live jedes christoph
häufig nicht zu spät an
wie geht es ihnen
danke für die noten
entschuldigen sie es kein
missverständnis ich haben ihre meldung
das wort bariton gelesen dass weiter und
noch die noten waren habe ich vor drei
wochen übersehen
ich habe sie einfach nicht gesehen
ich wollte sie fragen sind sie morgen
ausarbeiten
sie fliegen weg und wann fliegen sie weg
früh schon um sieben uhr morgens
entschuldigen sie bitte
ok dann bleiben wir in kontakt vielen
dank
hacker sieht man volksmusik geschlafen
[Musik]
meine zeit zum üben ist eh schon knapp
durch meinen vater habe ich drei wochen
verloren und live kann mir jetzt auch
nicht helfen
neuer tag neues glück
da der von der kommunal county ehemann
haben spontan zugesagt mit mir die noten
einzustudieren
das ist unser partner fassung geschickt
stell dir vor ich seit ein schüler ich
verstehe gar nichts ich weiß nicht wo
meine stimme ist muss ich den text lesen
oder singen er sagt immer über bariton
bo ist bariton überhaupt das ist dass
der bass teilt sich auf in bass und
bariton wo denkst du das kann man lernen
ohne die noten zu kennen
es wird ein langer weg
[Musik]
wieso bist du nicht tun
entschuldigung wo bist du es ist dann
sehr einfach ab einfach das einfachste
form einfach wenn ich singe muss ich
dann so stehen das ergibt sich von
selbst
das ist im moment unsere kleinste sorge
[Musik]
schon gut
das ist schwierig mit noten
[Musik]
bitte noch mal gefällt es hier
nein ein klares urteil der jungen profis
eigentlich ist stille nach der ein
einfaches lied doch diese ungewohnte
baritonstimme überfordert mich aber in
russland habe ich gelernt zu kämpfen und
das battle gladys mir eine gewisse
sturheit in die wiege gelegt und so übe
ich war nämlich neben meinem
korrespondenten job zeit finde auf dem
weg zu einer veranstaltung mit
oppositionellen im kurzurlaub in den
schweizer bergen
[Musik]
am polarkreis bei der einweihung einer
glasfabrik mit präsident putin
oder zu hause in moskau mit meiner
tochter malia
[Musik]
jetzt wird sich zeigen ob dirigent live
auch zufrieden ist mit meinen
fortschritten
ob er mich mit singen lässt
[Musik]
die
schön
[Musik]
sehen sie es ist gar nicht so schwierig
wie es anfangs schön und ja wenn sie im
chor singen erinnern sie sich daran als
ich ihm jetzt sagen
ein mensch der in einem chor singt kann
nicht unglücklich sein mag es auch
weihnachtliche milde sein von lew
jedenfalls steht meinem auftritt jetzt
nichts mehr im wege
es ist der sechste januar heiligabend in
russland wo man nach dem julianischen
kalender weihnachten feiert nicht einmal
in der nördlichsten millionen metropole
der welt liegt schnee die menschen haben
frei und sind in partylaune
und ich mache mich an die letzten
vorbereitungen viel mit ca durch die
tonne her ohne organisierte und fiel mit
einer gesungen aber jetzt fühle die
singen einfach und jetzt irgendwie
kollektionen mensch das habe ich viel
energie und allem aber es gibt wenig wie
die welsche mal das stimm beherrschen
weiß dass die menschen keine mir die
wade oder das derselben muskulatur in
schwung bringen ist die trainieren also
die begriffe und links und rechts also
eine harmonie kitsch schütteln club
gespielt vor weihnachten ich gratuliere
ihnen es wird heute alles gelingen viel
glück
naja die glaubten auch das ist das motto
und schon gut so
[Musik]
etwa um 23 uhr 30 die weihnachtsmesse
beginnen genau weiß man das in russland
nehmen
ich bin jedenfalls früh genug
was sein
das sind
denn nicht machen
[Musik]
mindestens zweieinhalb stunden dauert
die mitternachtsmesse das lied bei dem
ich mit singen darf kommt erst ganz am
schluss
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meine lehrerin sagte ich müsse mich gut
einsingen gar nicht so einfach hier
nicht hier lassen sie ihre hat gleich
sein auftritt nur ein bisschen
[Musik]
nach knapp zwei stunden werden der
heiligen kommunion eine pause für das
engl
gleich bin ich dran vieles hier erinnert
mich an eine katholische messe zu hause
in den walliser bergen
[Musik]
wo singen die baritone
stille nacht in einem arrangement von
left on a f
[Musik]
[Applaus]
euro
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich gratuliere danke frohe weihnachten
danke ihnen auch vielen dank dass ich
mit singen durch es war wundervoll mein
traum alles geklappt ich denke ja wie
schaffe ich nicht gestört
sie haben geholfen das ist das
wichtigste wir sagen hat es geklappt
danke was müssen sie beurteilen mich
alle nichts gehört das wichtigste ist
ich habe nicht mehr stören da die frohe
weihnachten
ich danke ihnen ich hoffe ich habe nicht
gestört zu hause alles in ordnung
li begrüßt sein jeden mann
danke dass sie mich damals gerettet der
chor möchte ihnen das schenken was
position und eine tasse mit dem bild der
isar das kapitale drauf gut verpackt für
den transport danke vielmals ich werde
diese nacht nie vergessen
[Musik]
so endete ein weihnachtliches abenteuer
mit einem happy end
und irgendwie ist diese geschichte
sinnbildlich für meine ganze zeit in
russland ein paar misstöne
aber alles in allem wunderschön
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge von ein anderes
russland fahre ich nach sibirien zum
baikalsee
dort gibt es eine insel namens ophone
sie soll voller energie und kraft orte
seien jedenfalls zieht sie sind suchende
aus aller welt an
hahaha